嗨大家好
我是魏士航醫師
這是 AI 告訴我
我 40 、 50 年後會是什麼樣子
那我必須說看到這張圖的時候
其實心裡是有點忐忑的
這時候我就會開始想說
40 、 50 年後
我真的能夠還是像現在一樣
精神飽滿的到處走跳嗎
或者是說
我會開始變得行動遲緩
然後思緒開始變得不清晰呢
我想這應該是螢幕前面
其實每一個朋友
都會感到焦慮的一件事情
畢竟
我們每個人其實都期待優雅的老去
但是老這件事情
難道我們真的就只能被動的去接受它嗎
今天我們就邀請到逆齡的最佳代言人
他是華佗門第 80 代傳人
同時也是詠生中醫診所的院長
那大家不要看他現在這個樣子
他其實從國中時代就開始長出白髮
到了高中
其實頭髮是滿頭白哦
那很多人還會說
這個背影看起來怎麼像阿公
那沒想到他就靠著一套的導引術
成功逆轉了他的白髮
同時也讓他其實到現在
精氣神都還比許多年輕人還好
那我們歡迎吳建東中醫師
魏醫師好
各位觀眾大家好
那其實我們今天呢
要討論的核心
其實就是吳醫師最新出的這本書
《 50歲起這樣練》
慢老中醫帶你增肌減脂、抗發炎、防失智
裡面最主要討論的核心
就是導引術
那導引術到底是什麼呢
其實對於我們一般人來說
聽起來會覺得這個詞彙有點陌生
甚至有點玄
那它到底跟我們常聽到的氣功
或者說在公園長輩練的八段錦
到底又有什麼不一樣呢
我們就請吳醫師先幫大家科普一下
這個導引術到底指的是什麼東西
那導引它其實是從古到今就一直用這個名字
那最近有一些新的名字出現
叫做氣功
大家可能比較熟悉一些
只是一樣的東西
然後那個名字不一樣而已
那它為什麼叫導引呢
它其實是兩個概念
導就是疏導的導
我們氣血在身體裡面走的時候
它會比較平和
比較平穩
這樣子叫導氣令和
引叫做引體令柔
就是說讓我們的身體比較柔軟
讓我們的關節的活動度比較大
那肌肉僵硬可以改善
所以是這兩個觀念
一個是練我們的氣
一個是練我們的身體
那我們的氣跟身體練好
自然人就可以比較健康
比較長壽
如果我們去 Google
比如說導引術或 Google 氣功
會出現幾個名字比較有名的
像是五禽之戲
太極拳
八段錦
年代最久的是五禽之戲
它是華佗發明的
它強度比較高一些
稍微難練一些
比較強調扭轉
練肌肉
練呼吸這個部分
難度稍微高一些
但是我覺得它的效果也最好
那接下來我介紹一下八段錦
八段錦在大概宋朝的時候就出現了
它只有 8 個招式
好 8 個招式很簡單易練
大概練個 5 分鐘就結束了
太極拳應該是全天下大家都知道的東西
它就比較偏向柔和、伸展、呼吸
這樣子的一個拳術
最早是從
明末清初的時候開始的
比如說太極拳很多招式都是一個防禦
一個攻擊
一個擒拿再一個反身
這樣的攻擊
但是現在我們在練這個太極拳的時候
比較少強調這個攻擊的部分
還是會教
但是比較多強調我們養生、呼吸
練我們的招式
練我們的筋骨這個部分
這樣聽起來
好像導引術
就是一個專注在呼吸跟肢體伸展
這樣的一個運動對不對
是
但對於像我這樣
在接受西醫訓練的人來說
我們常常就會想說
這功效到底是不是真的有科學實證
還是說
它其實就只是一個心理安慰
那不過其實後來我就發現
其實很多這種各界的頂尖人物
其實他們對導引術其實也很推崇的
像是台大的前校長李嗣涔教授
他其實長期就研究這個科學氣功
然後除此之外
像是我們的企業界的施振榮
然後演藝圈像翁倩玉、張艾嘉
甚至是前台中市長胡志強
他們都有提過
他們透過像氣功
或導引術這類的功法
來去幫助他們維持健康
增強體力
所以我後來就去查了一下
發現這導引術
其實有點像是透過我們這樣的運動
去幫助我們去達到一個
自律神經調節的一個潛能開發的一個功法
那實際上我們大概就知道
其實自律神經這件事情
其實對於我們現代人來說
其實非常關鍵
因為當我們如果說
能夠透過活化迷走神經
去活化這個副交感的一個作用的時候
其實我們身體才會真的從戰鬥模式
恢復到修復的模式
像我最近就看到一篇文獻
他說像這一類的運動
它其實可以幫助我們明顯改善這個 HRV 就是
這個心率變異率
在我們練習之下
我們的心血管的彈性
人體的抗壓性
其實都有明顯改善
那我知道其實吳醫師
自己本身在臨床上
然後也有很多研究上
其實都發現很多的實證
不知道可不可以跟我們分享更多呢
好的
其實我們從這幾十年來
一直都有相關的研究
太極拳
它針對幾個疾病
比如說肌纖維疼痛症
大概在 2010 年的樣子吧
新英格蘭醫學期刊(NEJM)的部分
裡面有提到
他做個研究
把兩組人
那一組是有練的
一組是衛教的
兩者做比較
然後他用一個叫做 FIQ
就是一個肌纖維疼痛症的量表
來做一些分析這樣子
發現說有練的人比一般衛教的
或是一般走路的
一般散步的話
肌纖維疼痛症患者的改善的程度
似乎有顯著的差異
所以像我們臨床上
有一些肌纖維疼痛症的患者
我們一樣
照常就開藥給他
甚至給他一些針灸
或是一些建議
治療的建議
當然這除此之外
我們也叫他去練功
簡單的練一下太極拳或八段錦
另外一篇也一樣
登在那個NEJM上面的期刊的一個論文
它寫有到說針對一些帕金森氏症的患者
Parkinson's Disease
它對於這個的症狀也是有顯著的改善
他會站比較穩
比較不容易跌倒
活動也比較順利一些
當然有其他更多的論文
針對比如說我們失智症
容易跌倒的
或者是一些認知功能的變差
也會有顯著的改善
其實這邊我也要呼應一下
腦部的退化或纖維肌痛症
其實發炎大概都扮演其中
最核心的那個角色
那我也有看到一篇
去年的期刊
其實他們就發現
其實練這套功法
不管是太極拳、八段錦
這類功法只要一段時間之後
其實都可以觀察到這些練習的人
他們體內的這個發炎指數
其實是明顯的降低
包括像是 CRP（C反應蛋白）
或 Interleukin-6（白血球介素-6）
這些指數都明顯的降低
那也意味著其實慢性發炎的狀況
可以透過這樣的練習來去改善
那其實
這在抗衰老醫學上面
其實是一個蠻重要的一件事情
因為我們知道
其實發炎因子
往往就是那些加速老化的
一個重要的因素之一
對
是 沒錯
而且除了發炎因子以外
我覺得剛剛提到的神經調控也很重要
是這樣子
那我們剛剛提到
大部分研究都是針對我們的表現嘛
那有人想說
我去實際去看一下
他的體內是不是有什麼變化
所以有一組人
他用那個 MRI 核磁共振
去掃腦部裡面的變化
他分成三組
一組是太極拳
一組是八段錦
一組是一般沒有什麼運動、久坐的人
做一些相關的比較
他發現說
在有練太極拳的人
或者是有練八段錦的人
比上久坐不運動的人
他的大腦灰質有顯著的增加
也就是說
這個灰色的部分跟我們的記憶
跟我們的思考會比較有相關
我們的腦容量
或是我們的大腦的活躍度就增加了
所以這個似乎可以一部分的解釋說
為什麼我們有練這些東西
我們比較不容易失智
甚至可以改善失智的症狀的這個原因
那我們剛聽吳醫師分析完
這些科學的實證的部分之後
那接下來我們就要進入大家最關心的
怎麼去應用
這件事情
那第一個我想跟大家談的就是這個
我們的體態雕塑
增肌減脂這個部分
那一般大家想到說我想要雕塑體態
想要增肌減脂
這個運動一定要很累很喘
那可是
我發現其實在中醫的理論
好像對於這個部分
反而更強調這個「脾胃」的功能
我們就會覺得很奇怪
像這種導引術這種溫和的運動
它是如何在增肌上面發揮它的功效的
那為什麼我們說這個導引之術可以增肌
是因為我們的導引術有一部分在練
我們的後天之本
也就是我們的「脾胃消化系統」
這個系統
從我們的嘴巴
到我們的咽喉
食道、胃、小腸、大腸
到我們的直腸出去
這整個這個管子
都叫我們的「脾胃消化系統」
包括我們外掛的一些器官
比如說肝臟、胰臟、膽囊
這也都算是我們的消化系統之一
那就中醫的理論來講
脾胃跟我們的肌肉息息相關
叫做脾主肌肉
也就是說你的脾胃好的話
我們的肌肉就會長得比較好一些
意思就是說
我們的消化吸收比較健康的話
我們有比較多的一個材料
去組成我們的那個肌肉系統
但是
您要跟肌肉講說
你要長大
要長大就是給它一些刺激
給它一些鍛鍊
如果肌肉要長大的話
就現在的醫學的理論
大概有三大理論
一個是機械張力
一個代謝壓力
肌肉微小損傷
這三個加起來
會讓我們的那個肌肉知道
它需要長大
我們這時候
就會練一些跟導引術相關的
或者是我們去做一些運動
或者做一些更強的一些重訓
這都跟我們的增肌有相關
我們如果說年紀比較大
可能不大適合太過刺激
或那個強度太高的話
我們練我們導引術就會有幫助這樣
其實這個部分呢
我們也可以從西方醫學的概念來去呼應
我們常常以為說
這個增肌的部分
其實就是阻力訓練就可以達成了
其實絕對不是這樣子哦
當我們的腸胃狀況不好
比如說腸道屏障受損
然後腸胃的吸收能力不好
持續發炎的狀態之下
我們就算吃再多的蛋白質
其實它也沒辦法真的長成
我們需要的肌肉
那也就是說
其實如果說能夠透過這樣的導引之術
把我們的脾胃顧好的話
其實我們這個時候
才能真正的把我們的肌肉養起來
那大家不要忘了哦
其實像現代人的肥胖
其實大部分是來自於胰島素阻抗
這是現代肥胖其實很重要的因素之一
那當我們有足夠的肌肉量的時候
其實我們可以去維持
我們身體的胰島素敏感度
那這時候
我們就可以阻止
這個胰島素阻抗的形成
等於說
我從基礎上面要去改善這個代謝
那自然而然
就可以幫助我們達到增肌減脂的功效了
我們來示範一下
五禽之戲裡面有個動作叫做虎撲鹿奔
它主要鍛鍊到的地方
是我們的大腿跟我們的臀部
全身上下最大的肌肉在這個地方
我們可以練一下
首先我們兩手比個讚
放在胸前好
往前跨一大步
蹲下去
我們的後腳的膝蓋
靠近腳跟
對
膝蓋不要超出
大概是這樣子比較好
對
這樣比較不會傷膝蓋
我們這樣固定好以後
我們就上下動
慢慢的動就好了
慢慢動
差不多
魏醫師我覺得這樣很標準
然後這樣蹲的話
可以按摩到我們的內臟
可以鍛鍊到我們的大腿臀部的肌肉
您覺得累的時候就站起來休息一下
對 真的還蠻酸的
第二個問題
我想要請教吳醫師的就是
關於失智症腦部退化這件事情
其實我們在診間
其實常常聽到這個患者跟我說
哇 最近出門了才發現
這個鑰匙忘了帶
或者說
前一秒明明還在想說
要講什麼話
結果頭一轉
就忘記了
剛剛準備要講的是什麼東西了
很多人會覺得說
這個健忘這件事情
會不會就是失智症的前兆
那就中醫來講的話
失智的發生
當然跟年紀的退化會有關係
我們叫做腦髓空虛
腦髓空虛
那麼腦髓空虛的話
有幾個原因
比如說我們剛剛提到的腎氣不足
先天的元氣比較弱了
沒有辦法補充我們的腦髓
因為腎主骨生髓嘛
所以腦髓不足
腎氣不足
也會導致我們的失智容易發生
那剛剛提到的後天的脾胃消化不良
也就是腸胃沒有辦法好好的吸收
我們的養分
甚至有一些發炎的現象出現
會導致我們沒有東西
可以去補充我們的腦髓
這個也會導致失智的發生
再來最後一個就是
我們講痰瘀阻絡
痰是我們水分體內的代謝變比較差
那麼水分變比較太過濃厚之類的
瘀就是循環不好了
有些血液的循環變差了
導致我們進入腦部的一個循環
氣血不足
或者是腦部裡一些代謝的老化產物
沒有辦法排出來
導致發炎
這也會導致失智容易發生
確實這部分呢
在西醫
也有類似的一個解釋
我們都知道
其實大腦它有個專屬的排毒系統
我們叫淋巴排毒系統
那其實它必須在我們循環好的時候
壓力比較偏低的時候
它才能良好的運作
那假如說
我們沒有辦法很好的運作的時候
其實很多大腦代謝後的一些廢物
比如說像是我們常聽到跟失智有關的這個
類澱粉蛋白
或者說濤蛋白
其實它沒有辦法順利排出的時候
往往就是造成我們這些失智症的源頭
所以我們來介紹幾招
跟頭部有相關的導引之術
我們來介紹五禽之戲的臉部按摩
跟頭部按摩
那我們現在要按摩臉部
就請我們把眼鏡拿下來
好 我們需要用我們的手
當然你用別的器具也可以
但是我覺得手最簡便
先摩擦一下
摩擦生熱
那我們自己在摩擦的時候
麻煩您手這樣交叉
因為我們的經絡是走在指手指的側邊
我們的經絡是走在手指的側邊
我們這樣按摩可以有效刺激我們經絡
我們按摩好以後
搓我們的臉這樣子
由下往上搓
那你要由上往下也可以
但是我們由下往上搓
比較不會有一些下垂的這個問題
讓我們的臉部的循環改善
我們再搓我們的頭部頭皮
我們的手指就插進我們的毛根這個地方
髮根這樣
由前往後梳
由前往後梳這樣子
來刺激我們頭皮的循環
那我們的臉部按摩之後
頭皮按摩之後
我們還可以按摩我們的耳朵
我們耳朵就這樣拉一拉
拉一拉
揉一揉
彈一彈
那我們為什麼要按摩耳朵
因為腎它開竅於耳
所以耳朵的循環好不好
也會跟我們的中醫講的
腎氣充不充足有關係
所以我們刺激這個地方
也有助於促進我們的那個腎氣充足
我聽說有的人也用一般的梳子梳
也算養生是不是
是 也算哦
所以我們在梳頭的時候
不拘我們的器材
但最好用的是手指
那如果你要梳頭的話
稍微挑一下
我們找那種比較大的梳子
我們不要找那種扁梳
我們最好找那種有彈性的梳子
或者是梳子的頭是圓圓的那種按摩梳
這樣子按摩的效果會比較好
那您大概按摩到什麼程度
你覺得頭皮有點癢癢的
覺得頭皮有一點點發熱
這樣就好了
不需要太多
也不需要太用力
以免去傷到我們的頭皮跟髮根
那耳朵也是
我們在按摩的時候
按摩到覺得耳朵有點熱熱的就好
不需要按摩到整個發熱
甚至有一些受傷的狀況
這樣子適當就好
現在點擊右上方連結
領取我整理的預防失智
關鍵營養素參考表
幫助你在生活中降低大腦退化的風險
接下來我們要討論的
可能大家會覺得很意外
其實就是青春痘的問題
這其實我自己有點私心
因為我三不五時其實也會冒個幾顆痘
我們一般想到青春痘都會想到
那我就找皮膚科
開點藥
然後去塗塗抹抹
幾天後
趕快讓它消
沒想到我們的導引術
其實對這類的問題也有所幫忙
請吳醫師來為我們介紹一下
是 我們青春痘會發生
主要就我們來講就是
火氣比較大
包括心火旺或肝火旺
都有可能是青春痘的一個主因
臨床上會依照青春痘的部位不大一樣
認為說他可能哪個地方的火氣比較大
或是我們靠那個脈診
來決定說火氣在哪個地方
最常出現的地方大概是心火
心火旺比較多
所以在八段錦裡面
有一招叫做搖頭擺尾去心火
我們就用這個方式
讓心火下降
回歸到我們的肝腎的地方去
然後心火減少以後
那個痘痘發炎的熱就可以減輕
但如果說你已經發炎到疼痛
化膿的程度
還是趕快找醫師治療一下的好
我們一樣馬步蹲下去
那兩手放在大腿上
身體從前面往後旋轉
這樣繞一圈
那我們再從另外一邊繞回來
我們用這一招來降一下心火
也就是調節我們的自律神經
這樣子
如果您覺得煩躁
憂鬱焦慮
睡不好覺
我們這個加減可以做一下
然後剛剛提到青春痘火氣大的
口乾舌燥的
這個也可以練一下
這樣子
其實我們剛剛聽到吳醫師分析的時候
我們發現
中醫其實對於青春痘這種概念
大部分都是認為是來自於肝火
那如果說以西醫來說的話
其實就是壓力系統的過度活化
那我們知道其實在壓力的狀態之下
其實皮質醇的分泌會上升
那這時候我們的皮脂腺
其實就會分泌大量的油脂
更重要的是
我們在壓力狀態之下
其實腸道的屏障會破損
那這種狀況之下
其實就會帶來慢性發炎的問題
那西醫其實有個概念叫做
腸皮膚軸（Gut-Skin Axis）
當我腸道破損的時候
這個全身發炎的狀況
反而會表現在皮膚上面
所以也就是說
其實真正要處理這個青春痘
對西醫來講
一個就是我們要掌控飲食
盡量不要吃一些
比如說中醫說的
上火的東西
那另外的話
其實更重要就是可以透過各種的方式
去調節那個壓力系統
好的 那我稍微補充一下
一些上火的東西
跟大家稍微列舉一下
比如說我們最常看到的發物
花生、堅果或是一些帶殼海產之類的
請大家就特別小心
那有些特別容易發的食物
像是水果的芒果
或是蔬菜的竹筍
也請大家稍微特別注意一下
接下來呢
很多人困擾的這個腰痠背痛的問題
在診間其實會發現
像這種腰痠背痛的問題
常常會持續蠻久的
當人們困擾於這樣的狀況的時候
其實那種焦慮感
或甚至會常常想東想西
一下想說
是不是腰椎
一下又想說
是不是哪一塊肌肉出了問題
幫我們示範個幾招
對腰痠背痛有幫忙的訓練方式
是
我們腰的活動大概有分兩組
一個是旋轉的動作
一個是俯仰的動作
好 今天真的很開心
就是沒想到
我們經由吳醫師這樣分析之後
我們發現
導引術並不是說
一般公園阿伯
他們在練的一個活動而已
其實它有深厚的這個理論基礎在
而且它不止還可以幫助我們
去強健體魄
對於像是青春痘
對於腦部
那其實也都有很大幫助
所以大家如果對於
想要更深入瞭解這些練功的細節的話
我想大家都可以去參考這本
《 50歲起這樣練》
慢老中醫
帶你增肌減脂、抗發炎、防失智這本書
裡面都有更詳細的圖解還有解釋
那最後我想請吳醫師來幫我們總結一下
假如說在這本書裡面
你覺得有一個觀念
是最想要分享給大家的
那會是什麼樣的一個觀念呢
我覺得
那個養生的部分
其實該從年輕開始就慢慢築基
你越早把健康的資本存下去
我們老化的就越晚
或是您的健康就會維持越久
所以盡早開始
永不嫌晚
所以養生
永遠不嫌晚
想要做就是從現在開始
假如說你喜歡今天的內容的話
不要忘了幫我們按讚、訂閱還有分享
如果你想要知道更多健康相關訊息的話
可以加入我們初日醫學官方的 Line 哦
那我們頻道會員的功能也開通了
期待大家趕快來成為瘦粉
我會和你們在頻道的會員專區相見哦
那我們今天節目就到這邊
大家下次再見
bye bye